guys if you've been following this
channel for the last couple weeks you'll
know
i've been looking everywhere for my
wonder woman beanie and i finally found
it
today and little did i know this wonder
woman 1984 opening scene
would drop i'm privileged
privileged this is a divine intervention
let's watch it
[Music]
some days hmm childhood feels so very
far away and others
they can almost see it
the magical land of my use like a
beautiful dream of when the whole world
felt like a promise
so green
looking
should watch back closely than
understood
but sometimes
return to that mascara
wow
oh we're back at it
a little bit more cgi than before but
that's all right you know gotta
go bigger cool
wow nice look at these women go
whoa cool my goodness
horse quidditch
those fans are gonna be on ebay
and etsy
[Music]
the glorious ladies of themyscira
that's cool that makes sense
i believe in the most seasoned warriors
i can do it just do your best
and remember greatness is not good
greatness is not what you think maybe
that's the theme of the movie
come on little die
oh cool again trailer territory
oh
[Music]
because she's the cheetah
yeah that was glorious that was just so
nice to step back into the
wonder again yeah no point i mean all
the
all the zack snyder will put it all the
[ __ ] pun intended
that's right dude wonder woman's gonna
kill some guy
she's gonna swear his mom out it's gonna
be great all right so we're not part of
the privileged
folk who were able to watch this movie
yet but i can already feel an opening
scene is so important
especially with establishing your themes
and then you know right away with the
narration of diana talking about how
there's lessons that lay ahead yet
unseen
saying how looking back i wish i
listened and that you know sometimes you
can't see what you're learning until
it's too late something like that
but that other line greatness is not
what you think there's a lot of
in that monologue that she's talking
about there or that opening narration
that seems to thematically be setting up
this
whole movie uh especially when they cut
into the trailer footage
showing that whatever experience that
however this olympic event goes down and
then whatever scenes follow afterwards
maybe with antiope and getting some more
learning lessons that
she's talking about how she had these
lessons laid out for her
in the beginning things that she should
have listened to to help her be more
aware of whatever
journey and it sounds like she's going
to be making some mistakes along the way
in this specific installment too i mean
yes there were learning lessons to be
had in the first wonder woman it seems
like this time around she's going to be
making some choices
that are a little bit detrimental things
that she should have been more aware of
based off of whatever we're going to get
further in this opening scene i like
that these learning lessons that we're
going to get in greatness is not what
you think
too especially knowing that maxwell
laura is going to be in here how they
use this stone to
grant some wishes for themselves the
greatness does not always equal power
i'm not sure yet
obviously we haven't seen the movie what
i love so far is that oh for an opening
scene it seems to really be
throwing you into what this movie's all
about right away just with that opening
narration
oh yeah absolutely and i think it makes
a nice compliment to the first movie
because so much of what she learns and
that is that the nature of
evil and conflict is not what you think
yeah and i feel like for a
sequel a follow-up you know you
obviously want an
even greater sense of heroism and
achievement and accomplishment and that
will probably come at an
even greater cost or at least through
greater obstacles and whatnot and uh
yeah that
at least gets me excited for thinking
okay what's gonna be the true nature of
the story once we reach the end because
you know i'm sure they've got some crack
writers on this i'm sure they're gonna
kind of want us
to be attacking the problem and
attacking you know the emotional side of
this as much as diane is or whatever but
uh
i just really liked seeing them as
secure again i love the way they
photographed it and i love the contrast
because
at first you're in such a natural lush
green
beautiful environment and then you do
yeah you switch over to something that
looks very much
more like cg but even then the credence
they lent to the scope of that
cutting in with like the chair the
horses and the scale and just seeing the
games happen
i always love when these things at least
take a little time to go back and go
like what's the society like and what do
these games
mean you know and i like that even
though that i expect in the movie this
scene will go on
longer and probably breathe more it does
make for a nice intercutting of like oh
okay well here are at least some of the
building blocks of where all these
amazing powers and skills came from you
know i thought that was a clever way
to segue us out of this clip you know
yeah it's a re-edited opening scene
anytime they say they're releasing the
opening scene nine times out of ten
it's still an edited down version of
what we're gonna get and it was nice to
see robin wright back here again
considering the events of the first
wonder woman just a combination of like
the different variations of the stunt
work you get to see on display that was
something
i was so impressed with the first film
and now you get to see it more here
right away which i thought was awesome
what i love too is like literally it's
the thematic stuff one thing that patty
jenkins seems to really get about this
character is the psychology of this
woman and you know everything with
psychology plays into who we were as
little children
and it like starting off right here in
this moment not only is complementary to
how the first wonder woman began but
also playing into the like the dna of
the psychology of
who diana is and you know like the
emotion versus the logical side of her
and how she should have listened to
these lessons but she followed her heart
and gave him the desires like i'm
combining all these thoughts from all
the trailer
knowledge i have in my brain also shouts
out to hans zimmer's awesome score you
can't talk in this video without talking
about that awesome tune can you peeps
no you cannot no you cannot i'm excited
to check this movie out we have hbo max
already
comment below if you don't have hbo max
and you're pissed off about it leave
country leave your country and come here
comes out on christmas we're gonna be
spending time with our families that day
so do not expect a review on christmas
day please sometime a little bit after
that a day or two or whatever
probably christmas eve christmas eve for
sure that's right expressvpn
trick those companies into not believing
you're any other country
click that notification bell subscribe
hit that like button last but not least
rosa para
rosa if there's a woman of wonder
at our patreon it's you
oh yeah okay christmas is
so good to you this year you know why
because you've been kicking
so much ass like the sexy feminist
scaring you
are you amazon you you amazonian
lady you i'm so proud of everything
you've accomplished you
better have a merry merry christmas
yeah you better celebrate with the
family and spoil them
spoil them with love and cheer and you
make sure to instill
that same level of strength that you
possess
into your children do you hear me rosa
do you hear me
you better be good to your kids this
year and i hope you have a happy new
year as well
because you know what i don't know what
resolutions you need
because it seems like you've been
resoluting all over the place in 2020
and it's
awesome yeah you're just achieving every
goal imaginable speaking of which i'm
going to be expecting from you that
wonder woman 84 review on christmas
morning because
if anyone's holding it down the review
game it's you
but uh more than anything
i just hope that you get a nice night to
yourself to uh
i don't know enjoy you screw this
up i love you rosa merry christmas
[Music]